[Music]
you were arrested in st. Kitts we're
gonna get right into this yeah arrested
in st. Kitts and I had a hard time
figuring out what it is you did wrong
I'm not even sure you did anything wrong
what happened their laws are just
completely different yeah like they can
play publicly the dirty version of your
material music but you can't perform it
because they saying at that point you're
crossing the boundaries of public
profanities so that you could hear a
profane version of one of your music the
party has the same music we're listening
to right if you go perform it it has to
be a radio version of it because I was
there I wasn't even you weren't even
supposed to perform at this event
someone dropped out at the last second
you said I'll go on I'll help out and
what happened and I sung the song yeah
and then the guy kept calling comes
because they definitely see a little
difference like more military life yeah
so he comes he goes mr. fifty he showed
respect I like that is that mr. fifty
yeah the things you say on the stage you
have to come with me I'm like what I'm
like I have to arrest you so they
literally did they take you to the did
you get arrested yeah I was in the
priest thing I had to sit there I was
sitting there I was like in the twilight
zone cuz I was like force am saying the
song yeah yeah there's like okay so just
just can't be so bad right you know and
then when they start telling you you
can't we need your passports yeah
don't wait a minute this is bad yeah so
they took it they wanted your passports
they wanted to kick you out of the
country and what was weird is you were
upset because you thought this is
there's a lot of crime there and say
yeah it's okay they like the murder
capital yeah so you've got me here for
saying mother and did you got a murder
rate higher than everyplace not
something
so they you thought there maybe their
values were a little skewed go catch a
murderer yeah
you